i want to start with the most important
thing how much i love eurovision
i mean i love that movie
so i'm just curious is that something
that people want to always talk to you
about is it just me
um my partner wants to talk about it
with me a lot actually my my
brother-in-law asked if i would send a
video to his friend who he said has been
watching it too much
he's like i don't want to talk about
eurovision with him anymore will you
just send him a video
so we can be done with this it's very
it's very sweet very flattering i'm a
very i'm a big fan of david and i think
that you uh
all of you guys did such a great job on
that thank you and the music is really
good again there's a reason i'm bringing
it up with you
really good
like i really enjoy that movie um
so obviously i want to talk to you
because i saw the first 15 20 minutes of
doctor strange oh did you yeah and so
they showed it here at cinemacon right
and you're very i'm just curious like
what did it mean being able to work with
sam rainey and go back to playing that
character again
i
i love sam so much you know he's he's
just such a pro
but he's so humble
and so collaborative he's the nicest man
you know it's always those ones that do
the horror films that are so nice it's
so strange like wes craven same thing
nicest most soft-spoken
person you know and then they just
exercise it all
on the screen which is the best place to
do it so i loved working with sam and i
loved this character i was so happy we
were back with her and with benedict
he's one of the greatest actors to get
to work opposite you don't have to work
at all he just does it all for you you
just stand there and listen it's great
um but i i was so happy to be back and
part of it did you want to tease
anything about the movie or
i don't think i'm legally allowed to do
that sure i'll just say that you're in
it i am in it definitely and i have more
than one scene
okay well there we go um jumping into
why i get to actually talk to you you're
very selective about what you take on
what was it about um
are you there god like that said i want
to do this
i mean
the fact that judy bloom was giving her
blessing after 50 years
for that movie to finally be made for
the book to be adapted was
i think a really big deal um it's so
iconic it's it's such a huge part of so
many people's childhoods
and for that very reason scary to take
it on you know because you want to live
up to what everyone's imagined all these
years but um fortunately you know i had
some leeway with my character because
she's bigger
more expanded in the film than in the
book but
um i just felt like it was a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and and i
loved judy bloom so much grew up reading
her and uh it felt pretty surreal to be
in that company
is there anything you want to tease
people about the film like what they can
look forward to or
um
i think it's like a grown-up movie about
adolescence that that
young people and grown-ups will enjoy i
think it's really really honest about
how hard it can be
being a young person and being a mother
and being a father and
how weird it is to be a human
sure
um so i think it's just so so relatable
i think it's gonna inspire so much
conversation
i think it's gonna be an event you know
in the theaters which we're all so
excited to get back to and i think this
is gonna
provide a lot of that i don't know if
they're still there that void you know
fill that void that's been missing um
yeah i don't know hopefully it'll it'll
be a lot of fun on that note i need to
stop with you i'm just gonna say i wish
you nothing but the best and congrats on
everything
you